- And I told him by email that I was--
the good news, I will be coming to London
for about a eight month long job.
And I said "I'm not gonna
tell you what it is,
"but it's not theater."
And he sent back an email saying,
"my guess is it's this
show called The Crown.
"About the English royals.
"What role would it be?
"The prince, the old king?
"If it's Winston Churchill you should know
"that every actor in London
"will have a contract out for you."
(audience laughing)
And I sort of swallowed
hard when I read that.
A couple of weeks later
Nick was in New York
and I had supper with him
and a lot of other friends.
And I got in the taxi with him and I said,
"Nick, it's true, it's
Churchill, in The Crown."
And his answer was "they will kill you."
(audience laughing)
And he said it without any irony at all.
And I really was frightened.
And I also didn't know whether The Crown
was gonna be any good.
Boy was it ever good.